madame la ministre vous êtes en train de
préparer un texte sur les mobilités et
il semblerait que dans ce texte il ya
des dispositions qui prévoient la mise
en place de péages urbains
alors moi je suis un élu de la première
couronne et ce que je vois dans ces
dispositions c'est surtout une
réglementation qui va sans doute être
lucratif pour certains et punitifs pour
tout le restant puisque après les les 80
km heure après les taxes sur le
carburant maintenant on va les prendre
l'argent dans la poche de ceux qui sont
obligés de prendre leur voiture et qui
n'ont pas d'autre choix pour aller
travailler
donc quand va cesser ce matraquage
fiscal qui était évoquée ici à plusieurs
reprises par ailleurs on nous a présenté
la métropole du grand paris comme une
espèce de panacée universelle pour
régler tous les problèmes de la région
capitale
et pourquoi donc pourquoi donc régler
les problèmes au niveau de la capitale
de paris pourquoi créer une espèce si
cela se fait de barrière entre des
arrondissements qui seraient devenus des
cars est privilégiée et nos villes de
banlieue qui sera encore une fois mise
au ban madame la ministre le transport
c'est la colonne vertébrale de la région
ile-de-france et si les gens prennent
leur voiture ça a été dit mais je crois
que ça m'a aidé et répéter si les gens
prennent la voiture c'est parce qu'ils
n'ont pas le choix s'ils ne font pas par
plaisir et s'il est aussi les transports
étaient plus confortable plus sûr plus
ponctuels et plus accessible et bien
évidemment on n'en serait pas là alors
ma question elle est simple est-ce que
vous croyez pas que plutôt que de
financer des infrastructures punitive
privative de pouvoir d'achat à terme
pour les gens et secouez pas qu'on
devrait travailler sur ces problèmes
matic de mobilité en concertation avec
la région métropole dont c'est la
compétence
merci la parole à madame elisabeth
bornes ministre chargé des transports
pour deux minutes
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur payzac
je crois qu'il faut arrêter de faire
croire que le gouvernement mènerait une
politique anti voiture quand dans la loi
mobilité on augmente de 70 % les crédits
pour remettre en état nos routes
nationales quand on prévoit un plan de
désenclavement routier d'un milliard
d'euros c'est bien parce qu'on est
conscient que la voiture est importante
pour se déplacer alors s'agissant des
péages urbains
je voudrais mettre aussi les points sur
les i il n'est pas question que l'état
n'incite à fortiori n'impose à quiconque
de mettre en place des péages urbains
c'est d'ailleurs le sénat c'est une
disposition qui existe dans la loi
depuis près de dix ans et c'est
d'ailleurs le sénat sur la base d'un
amendement de votre ex collègue louis
qui l'a introduit en 2009 dans la
loi grenelle mais cette possibilité
s'est révélé flou donc ce qui est
envisagé dans le projet de loi mobilité
c'est uniquement d'encadrer le
dispositif qui existe déjà pour garantir
qu'il reste proportionnée et par exemple
il y aurait l'obligation de consulter
les communes limitrophes
en cas de mise en place d'un péage
urbain et la mise en place de tarifs
plafonds donc moi je le répète ce n'est
pas l'état qui décideraient de mettre en
place un tel outil ça n'est pas non plus
l'état qui ont récupéré les recettes
ce sont les collectivités qui pourrait
décider de le mettre en place si elles
le souhaitent
et ça serait donc un outil parmi
d'autres à leur disposition parce
qu'elle nous l'ont demandé
dans les assises nationales de la
mobilité et c'était dur est ce qui
explique très bien votre collègue
fabienne keller dans le rapport sur les
péages urbains remis au mois d'octobre
jean merci merci il reste neuf secondes
pour la réplique chers collègues vous ne
les utilisez
je voudrais juste dire que ce qui est
important c'est que l'état peut être
travail avec la région régions métropole
et fassent tout ce qu'il faut pour
éviter qu'on rajoute la thrombose actuel
et que on arrête de fiscaliser de créer
des impôts supplémentaires je crois que
des économies à faire par ailleurs
plutôt que de toujours imaginer des
sources d'imposition nouvelle